Robert Woods joins me here on the show
how are you doing Robert how you doing
I'm doing well thanks for having me on
so you got it so do you knew you were
going to the house right at third and 33
you're like I feel it right that
happened I just saw I know initially
honey playing I had a whole lot of space
I knew where my blockers were coming
from and pretty much you know they did
block and went untouched and just just
ran do do all the work and just find the
lane and I guess now possible happened
in 1333 four times now exactly now
what's next third and 34 right Robert
[Laughter]
I'll tell you what Robert I don't even
know if you can call this this this
offense on schedule it's it's on
something I mean it's unbelievable what
is it like to be part of a group
performing as you guys are right now
exciting as competitive but it starts it
starts on the practice field we enjoy
somehow we compete we push each other
and it's just one one team go we enjoy
practicing we enjoy playing together and
we play together on this well give me an
example of the competition when you say
competitive that would not be a word
that I think fans would be used to
hearing describing an offense that's on
tilt like this yeah just how we just how
we practice we it's not only receivers
but another see your room you know came
on Cooper Co you know Sammy Watkins
Cooper wall running running our practice
so trying to put pretty much put
highlight plays on the practice little
thing with Todd Gurley and I mean
they're tracking our speed we're
practicing hard and I mean world I mean
we black sauce and we practice hard so
let me get out there on Sunday you know
as you know it's just like practice we
practice hard we practice how we play
Robert woods here on the Rich Eisen show
let's talk about your journey a little
bit here did you ever think you'd be
back at the Coliseum playing football
again and you left us see Robert it
now I did and I thought you know that's
my last time let's plant the Colosseum I
got an opportunity class it was Buffalo
playing against the Rams
and then like I thought that was my for
sure last opportunity and you know got
signed with the Rams and it's the whole
stadium whole field and they're playing
there for years and I thought love love
stadium look at all and do you ever have
a moment with Sammy Watkins in that in
that receiver room when you're hearing
about the offense that's being dialed up
and how how you guys are performing well
in it just looking at each other two
former Buffalo Bills to just say can you
believe we're in this situation together
do you ever have those moments with Sam
yeah every week every day we did I mean
is this you know different situations
we're out here running game the
offensive role you know the air game is
rolling the ground game is going and I
mean we just we just look at it and we
just we enjoy become my hair and work
with believe in this system and and it's
not it's not just me a family as well as
the players who were here before you
know world and press play we know
there's a lot more in store but uh I
mean we believe what he said and we're
working for we're working towards it
each and every day and like he preaches
we all have that we not me myself so
what what impresses you about McVeigh
Robert his plays is play calling a
creativity like I mean it's this
football you know you see the same place
you usually see the same play and then
you got me back over here creating play
seems like it's creating route-finding
windows and that that kind of offense
you know it it's fun to play in cuz you
know you know you're not just running
over the standard office or running you
know different type of routes things the
guys haven't seen before and allows us
to be creative another woman clay and
defenses they defense they never know
what's coming they never know what kind
of routes are running because they're
there so many routes and so many other
complements that play out of there
and now you've seen firsthand Todd
Gurley up close what
done in the last eight weeks how
valuable is he where would you put him
on the valuable rating of guys that
you've played with the guys that you've
seen on other teams that are considered
valuable where do you put Todd Gurley
for you Robert woods uh at the top you
know very very well at the top you know
well-deserved he comes out here and you
first look at him you know he's a beast
you know huge legs and sizes you see the
strength and then when you when you see
him run you know he could fly you know
there's this past week here at the top
speed of uh and and on our team you know
what this run but with this size such a
powerful runner you see what he does in
our pass game you see what he does in
our run game
the see what he does on the goal line
you know contributing everywhere on this
field instead of team success you know
he's one of our leading scorers but uh
he's really just you know keeping this
team going and the situations when we
feel like we can't get out of you know
Tiger Lillies there on a check down or
something you know bringing us through
what do you mean by top speed you guys
have this thing measured in practice or
during the games what are you talking
about both both we all today we're
having our speed check pretty much and
uh we're tryna we're trying to roll
we're just trying to compete you know
retreats on top of speeds and then you
know get ready to get ready for Sunday
and do it again on Sundays but uh that's
the kind of talk I say what was it see
know we're competing out here practice
but those monitors allow us you know to
go hard to compete and even push
yourself even more when you hear if the
next guy is running this or the other
guys run at this know you're always
trying to compete in and be faster
really and that's what the doctor Robert
Woods here in the Rich Eisen show have
you won a speed check lately have you
won one yeah 33 but honestly which play
which played a girly beat John I want to
say it was a second the second player
game for his first pretty much are open
and dry first big play he end up in at
top speed factors be who breaks this
news to you I this is first I'm kind of
hearing this speech speech
we gotta we gotta change the numbers
next week well I don't know Robert I
mean I do know some people in the NFL
I'm not saying I would you know cook the
books or anything like that but you know
oh maybe I would to be very honest with
you what's it worth yeah yeah check it
out now in all seriousness though Robert
there was a lot of conversation in
Rodney Harrison called called out Eli
Apple on on that play that we referred
to that third and 33 went right up the
gut he on NBC just circled a lot of
Giants players saying they quit did you
think the Giants quit on their team on
that in that game on Sunday yeah look I
look at ourselves I know we played the
full game we played on all four quarters
competitive you know we don't worry
about you know how our opponents play if
we don't try to match her you know we
like to play our game we like to play
you know for fourth quarter for four
quarters
and compete to the max you know every
unit wall offense defense and special
teams you know okay we're really just
worried about this Rams team and how we
practice it how we play and and we just
we love this team left to compete you
know every play all right all right so
you took the high road on me right there
well done Robert very very well done I
noticed that you know d-did you hear
Dion's line that he doesn't know the
address of the high road I guess you
know the address of the high road yeah
what is Houston presenting on film for
you checking him out as you got Houston
coming in with Tom savage and deshaun
Watson sadly not being there anymore
yeah just watching among you know
essentially or defensively has to say
you know we're watching and we see a
Joseph on the corner Jackson on outside
competitive group of guys you know back
there clowny always causing problems
though you know we got we got a tough
task ahead of us you know you know there
are still a good team you know they're
losing their quarterback but you know
it's still it's still an NFL these teams
are competitive you know they got a
quarterback so he knows how to win games
but you know we got to take care of
business at home and get this win okay
and I'm sure you're going to be an
interested observer in this
Thursday night football game here in
Arizona between the Cardinals and the
Seahawks what do you say to those who
say they don't believe in you and the
Rams and the ability to win a division
or playoff game or even something bigger
until you beat Seattle what do you say
about that Robert yeah well maybe we
don't worry about it we we know what
this thing can do we we're not really
looking at the outside so we're taking
it one game at a time we know we have
both teams on our schedule you know and
in their future coming up but as of
right now we know we're focused on
Houston horn and Seattle we have a
chance to play them again man you're
just on the high road right now you
should need an oxygen tank I mean
usually it's just one game I don't know
I mean it's it's you're on the
mountaintop right now your high road
knit your one game at a time and me I
mean you know I mean you got the
Seahawks doing what they did in the past
and they came in your house and they
beat you there's no there's no sense of
like wanting to get back out there and
and prove something to those who need
proving Robert yeah most most of them
poorly is more to what ourselves we knew
we were in a competitive game we end up
you know slipping up at the hand we
missed out on touchdown earlier in the
game so a lot of the mistakes in that
game where more are more on our part so
that's kind of why we're not really I
mean we're looking at opponents but we
know is more more about us you know we
feel like we control the game you know
what we do in our aspect the controlling
the ball turnover you know that's how we
win games and stuff like that so dad oh
yeah there's a you know a competitive
decent defense great defense they always
find ways to stick around and win games
of Russell Wilson so we know it's gonna
be competitive when we play them but I
mean we got and play them up there but
we know it's just all about it's all
about this team and what we do what we
could control and if we you know protect
the ball and you know do what we're
supposed to do you know stop them on
defense and put our points on offense we
we know you know we should end up with a
win up in Seattle when I when that time
comes all right Chris Brockman my he's
my
my own air compadre here Robert Woods
refused to say the Giants quit and that
they're gonna kick the Seahawks ass next
time they see him you just great John
with you Robert Congrats on everything
going on right now it's exciting to
watch exciting to watch you know this
happened in Los Angeles too it's good
good stuff thank you keep it going and
keep this messy room
okay well chat soon that's Robert Woods
of the Rams the Los Angeles Rams the 6
and 2 leading in the NFC West Los
Angeles Rams here on the Rich Eisen show
for more Rich Eisen show tuned to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Rich Eisen show app